[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
هدف تاريخي سجلته دوله قطر عام 2010 حين
تم اختيارها لاستضافه مونديال 2022 اول
دوله عربيه تخرج من مقاعد الاحتياط الى
ملاعب النجوم كمضيفه لاهم مسابقه لرياضه
كره القدم
على الدوله المضيفه سيل من ضربات الجزاء
حول تعاملها مع ملفات حقيقيه تبدا
بالعماله الاجنبيه ولا تنتهي بالحريات
الفرديه مخالفات بالجمله ادت الى غياب حفل
الافتتاح الرسمي عن شاشات ومنصات الاعلام
الاجنبيه ومن وراء حائطها الدفاعيه قدمت
الدوحه مواجهه حاميه بين تبني الانفتاح
على العصر من جهه والتمسك بالقيم العربيه
والاسلاميه من جهه اخرى فهل ازعجت قطر
الغرب فعلا فتتصدت لهجمه عنصريه ولبقايا
الاستشراق كما قيل ورويه ام انها خلطت
حامل الكره بنابلس السياسه والدين فكان
مونديال التابوهات في فلك الممنوع
يا ايها الناس انا خلقناكم من ذكر وانثى
وجعلناكم شعوبا
وقبائل لتعارفوا ان اكرمكم عند الله
اتقاكم
من ايات قرانيه البينه
في قطر
وفي الدوحه شيخ هندي يبشر بالاسلام وفي
الدوحه فيديوهات عن معتنقين جدد
اما على المدرجات فغابه المشروبات
الكحوليه
ايضا الاعلام الامازيغيه لان الوانات تذكر
ربما بقوس القزح وفي الملاعب اعترضت بعض
الفرق
دوله المنظمه عادات وتقاليد تغنى بها جزء
من الجمهور ووصفها جزء اخر
ايضا السنه المعلقين الرياضي
[تصفيق]
كل ذلك
العمال الاجانب في قطر عمال منهم من لقى
احدفه خلال حمله الاعمار التي سبقت تنظيم
المونديال الاعلى كلفه في تاريخ هذه
المنافسه
نيبال مسانده لافراد عائلته
دين وجنس وسياسه فالثلاثاء المحرم كان
بدوره راعيا غير رسميا لمونديال قطر 2022
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اهلا بك يا منير لديك غضب كبير على هذه
النسخه من كاس العالم تعتبر ان دوله قطر
لا تستحق ان تستضيف هذا العرس الرياضيه
هلا شرحت لنا وجهه
ليست الدوله
حفل العالمي مثل هذا قطر الدوله لا تحترمه
حقوق الانسان لا تحترم حقوق المثليين في
قطر همم هناك حكم الاعدام من اجل المثليين
الجنسيه اذا كنت قطري اذا كنت مسلم ام اذا
كنت اجنبي في سبع سنوات سجن هذه هي قطر
وقطر يعني تسجن
المخالفين
وليس لديها لا برلمان ولا حكومه ديمقراطيه
وانا اعتبر ان همم اعطاء يعني همم
عمليه تنظيم كاس العالم لكره القدم لقدر
كان خطا كبير وهناك اييي شبهات رشاوي تحوم
حوله
شكرا
راي استاذ العلوم السياسيه الاعلاميه
الدكتور علي الهيئه اهلا بك دكتور علي ما
تفضل به السيد منير هو جزء من راي عام
تتشطبه اليوم شريحه كبيره من الناس خاصه
العاملين في المجال الحقوقي كيف تقرا هذا
الراي وهل تعتبره محققا
انا احترم والقطريون والعرب والمسلمون
بشكل عام يحترمون جميع ثقافه شعوب كما
يحترمون ثقافتهم ثانيا انا احترم وجهه نظر
الجميع واحترم وجهه نظر همم الاخ منير من
مرسيليا وان كنت لا اتفقوا معها ولا
اتبناها للاسباب التاليه
الاهم الان اننا همم قضينا اكثر من تسعه
ايام ممتعه وركز اكثر من مليون و500,000
زائر لدوله قطر من مختلف زوايا الارض على
كره القدم واستمتعوا بمشاهده كره القدم
والقافله تسير الى يوم 20
الشهر القادم بمشيئه الله عندما يقول الاخ
منير كان خطا كبيرا
الموافقه على ان تستضيف دوله قطر كاس
العالم لماذا يقول عن يتكلم عن الرشا يعني
هي باللغه العربيه الرشا وليست الرشاوه
يتكلم عن الرشا هذا الامر لم يتم اثباته
على الاطلاق
والاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم نصب لجنه من
اجل هذا الامر وهذه اللجنه كانت لجنه
موضوعيه منصفه لا تاخذ جانب قطر ولا تاخذ
همم جانب الاخرين ولم يستطيعوا ان يثبتوا
ذلك ثانيا ملف دوله قطر الذي نفست غاليه
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه كان ملفا
نظيفا منذ 2010 الى حتى هذا اليوم وتقال
لنا الحملات المسعوره التي دوافعها عنصريه
وانا اريد ان اؤكد كما اكدت تحت الهواء
لاحدى الزبيلات في فنكات الفرنسيه بان
الموضوع ليس موضوع صراع حضارات هذا الكلام
هذا كلاش اوف كلانس
حقوق الانسان
عربيه اسلاميه مع العلم اننا سنناقش لاحقا
مساله الثقافه العربيه تسلمي لي هل هناك
فعلا ثقافه عربيه اسلاميه واحده همم ان
هناك ثقافات يعني العالم العربي
فرنسا عندما تجرد الفتاه المسلمه من
حجابها الا يعد هذا انتهاكا لحقوق الانسان
على سبيل الانسان الفتاه المسلمه من حجمها
ابدا ولكن عليه حال
ساعطي الكلمه للسيد منير قبل ان تعرف عباق
الضيوف ساعود اليك الدكتور علي خليك معنا
ماذا عن حقوق العمال
6,500 عاما الذين
تحدثها بالتفصيل نتعرف من موريال عبر
سكايب على الكاتب امين اهلا بك بشير انت
كتبت عن مقاطعه مونديال قطر فقلت مستفز
ربما قطر حق التنظيم لهذه البطوله ما هو
المستفز بالتحديد برايك وهل تعتبر ان
المقاطعه كانت قد تكون مفيده في مكان ما
ممكن المقاطعه تكون همم قرار شخصي بنهايه
الامر همم البعض قد يقاطع والبعض قد لا
يقاطع لكن تنظيم قطر لهذا المونديال اولا
همم مشبوه بسبب الرشاوي اللي ذكروها
الزملاء في الاستديو همم لكن لانه قتل
تفرض شروطها اليوم على المجتمع العالمي
وعلى الفيفا ايضا يعني هم من جانب هم من
يسيسون اللعبه هم من يضعون موضوع صراع
الحضارات التي ذكره الاستاذ علي همم
دكتور علي يعني هو يقول اليوم هناك حمله
ممهجه على قطر لانها دوله عربيه لديها
خصائصها كما قال وبالتالي هناك حمله على
هذه الدوله همم وهي حمله سياسيه فعليا انت
تقول انها لا تستحق لانها تريد ان تفرض هي
كيف تفرض برايك اليوم قطر سياستها دوره
كره القدم انا براي انا براي هناك جانبين
مهمين همم في ما تقوم به قطر عن طريق
الاسلام اولا هي تكرر لنفسها بانها تكون
المتحدث الاول والوحيد باسم العرب
والمسلمين وهي تدغدغ مشاعر همم اليمين
المحافظ العربي بانه هي قبله الاسلام وهي
ستحافظ على العادات والتقاليد واي وعادات
وتقاليد هذه هي عادات وتقاليد الاسلام فقط
وهذا الاسلام لا يعبر عن جميع من يعيش في
هذه المنطقه همم انا اليوم كردي الثقافه
الاسلاميه لا تمثلني هناك همم لا يعتبرون
لنفسهم المسلمين حتى ولو ولد كمسلمين فقط
تحاول ان تتحدث باسم جميع هؤلاء همم الناس
بانها همم تدافع عن حقوق
المسلمين وعن عاداته وتقاليد المسلمين
الجانب الاخر هو انه قطر هي تكرر ثنائيه
القطبيه بين الشرق والغرب هي التي تقول
اننا سنبهر العالم بان العالم يقوم بحمل
مسؤول عليها لانهم مسلمون ولانهم عرب ولكن
همم
الدافع الانتقاد هو دافع الاحتجاج على همم
حقوق الانسان في قطر حقوق المثليين همم
امبارح شفنا انه همم من ضمن المدرجات قطر
مناعت حمل لافتات همم تتعاطف مع النساء
الايرانيات والنساء الكرديات في ايران هذا
قمع ربما قد يقول لك البعد السياسه ليس
على الملاعب ايضا نناقش هذا الامر بالعوده
الى الملف الحقوق يريد ان اسال الضيف هنا
في الاستوديو والعضو في منظمه العفو
الدوليه النائب عن الشباب في الحزب
الاشتراك ديمقراطي الالماني محمد اهلا بك
يا محمد همم لديك تحفظات كبيره تتعلق بهذا
المدير على المستوى الحقوق يعني المستوى
الانساني وكيف تقرا الاجابه للحاصل اليوم
همم اريد ان اتكلم بشكل
خاص عن حقوق العمال همم المهاجرين الذين
هاجروا الى قطر
لاجل لقمه العيش في بدايات عام 2010 انا
انسان مقاطع المونديال ومقاطعه المونديال
لها اسباب انسانيه بحتها اليوم يتم اااه
بعد العديد من العمال يمكننا ان نتطرق الى
الاعداد لاحقا فهناك تداخل كبير في
الاعداد وعلينا ان نصرت الضوء على العدد
الصحيح
لكن ابدا من عام 2005 عام 2005 حظر ثلاث
اطباء يعملون في وحده العنايه المركزه في
مشفى حمد من مخاطر من مخاطر ضربه الشمس
والتوصيات تقليل ساعات العمل عندما تكون
الحراره عاليه في عام 2017
عام 2019 نشرت المجال العلمي لامراض القلب
اا ورقه بحثيه تفيد النسبه كبيره من
النفايات وفيات العمال المهاجرين كانوا
اني باليين في في قطر بسبب ضربه الشمس
15 حاله حاله يكتب على شهاده الوفاه بانهم
قد توفوا
وفاه طبيعي وهذا غير كافي لا تستطيع ان
تكتب على شهاده وفاه انهم قد توفوا
وزوي هؤلاء العمال يستحقون معرفه الحقيقه
كيف همم
ظروف عمل مشرفه بسبب عدم احترام السلطات
القطريه لحقوق العمال الذين يعملون في
ظروف ربما همم بيئيه او مناخيه قاسيه
الدكتور علي تفضل تريد ان تقول شيئا ما
اريد ان اذكر التالي الذي فعلناه نحن من
اجل شركائنا في التنميه العمال الاسيويين
دوره قطر تفردت على مستوى العامه العالم
بنظام حمايه الاجور ذا ويركرز بروتكشن
سيستم
والاخ الذي تحدث معك قبل قليل ربما لا
يعرف هذا الامر ان ثمه شركات تعسفت في
حقوق العمال صحيح ولكن هذا الحكومه ليست
مسؤوله عنهم والشعب القطري ليس المسؤول
عنه هذه شركات اجنبيه وبالمناسبه هي شركات
اوروبيه ومتهمه بالنفاق من قبل همم الذي
يقول انا صحيح اوروبي ولكن لا اشعر انني
اوروبي وهو جياني انفانتينو رئيس الاتحاد
الدولي لكره القدم هي اي شركات اوروبيه
غضبت الطرف عن هذه الشركات ولكن نظام
حمايه ويركرز برتكشن سيستم لم يغضوا الطرف
بل حاسبه وسال تلك الشركات وعمل لها حظرا
يعني اعطاه بلوك لا تستطيع ان تعمل اي شيء
في حسابها يعني في الحساب الخاص
بالشركه يقول الاخ الذي تحدث معك قبل قليل
ان ااه حدثت همم وفيات كثيره للعمال اولا
اولا منظمات حقوق الانسان ذاهو من رئيس
[موسيقى]
دوج هذه الشركه هذه المنظمات اولا هي
منظمات مسيسه بمئه
وشواهد كثيره استطيع ان اقولها لك لماذا
هي مسيسه 100%
هذه
المنظمات التي تدعي انها منظمات لحقوق
الانسان اين نهى عن فلسطين اين لها عن
الشعب العراقي الذي قتل اكثر
سيدي وامنسي ايضا هناك تقارير تصيرنا نحن
كحفيين بشكل بشكل دائري منورين
وضع العمال في الواقع صحيح قبل
المونديال تقريبا بعشر سنوات كانت هناك
همم يعني كان هناك خلل كانت هناك هناك
ولكن
المونديال
هناك مدن عماليه انشئت فيها جميع وسائل
الرفاهيه
فقط
في الصيف وفي الايام الحاره الساعه
الثانيه عشر ظهرا يتوقف العمل
كيف ترد ان تعلم تفضل به لانه يعني ما
يقوله ربما وساذهب الى اليك منير دقيقه
حتى الادنى للاجور هذه ليس النقطه ههه همم
حديثه بالنسبه لي انا اعيش في المانيا
وعضو في الحزب الاشتراكي الديمقراطي الذي
يدعم حد الادنى للاجور
حتى لو كانت هناك شركات
تقوم باستغلال العمال المهاجرين اين دور
الحكومه ان ان ان تضع احد لهذه
الشركات
والانتهاكات
تابع له وزاره العمل
وزاره الدوله
القطريه ان تراقب هذه عمل هذه الشركات
تفضل ماذا تريد ان تعلق قبل ان يتعرف على
ضيفنا الاخير تفضل
لم يجب
الاستاذ علي عن عن مسعد عن حقوق المثليين
يعني الحقوق العمال
اتحدث لك عن المثليين انتم لم تعطوني
سنفتح الحديث عن مثليين بعد قليل
المصري
على شاهد عيان على خبير في هذا الشان هو
همم يعني همم مهتم بمجموعه الالتراس وخبير
الالكتروني في موقع الدرج محمد غربيه هو
في الدوحه الان محمد ايضا كان في اخر
موديل اقيم في موسكو وهو اليوم في
المونديال قطر واريد ان اسالك محمد اهلا
بك اولا من خلال مشاهداتك هل تعتبر ان قطر
تتعرض في مكان مالي حمله غير مبرره على
صعيد التقصيره او انتهاكها للملفات
الحقوقيه همم
بيحضروا فوتبول كل اربع سنين مره
لكراتير الدوله المضيف لكاس العالم هي
اصلا مش واضحه ومثل من روسيا قبل روسيا
وبعدين الولايات المتحده
من قطر لملف تبعها وبي رايي الفيفا عيان
وقت لما كان ساب بلاتر هو الرئيس مثلا قطر
الجيزه وقدره اتخذها لانه هي الملف اللي
قدمته الملف بالنسبه الي فيه يكون ناقص
فيكم مش مضبوط في كل لازم يكون غير طريقه
لا شك بس
او اي دوله تستضيف بطوله العالم لكره
القدم هي عاده من وراء يعني الفيفا منه
النظام ديموقراطي وما بتمثل الشعوب بتمثل
منظمات كره قدم هو كفر يعني تاسس في
السبعينات هيجيء بس نقطه يعني حتى تكون
اساسيه لما احنا بالساهل من ما بيستاهل ده
قدم كره القدم
البطوله بطوله لهلا عصاعت كره قدم من
بطوله جدا
من يعني انجح البطولات على سعيد كره القدم
نفسها على الصعيد ثاني لا شك فيه كثير
امور نحكي فيها وعن كل موضوع راح نحكي فيه
بس بس في نقطتين بس بدي اسكنرون الموضوع
العمال الاجانب اذا احنا بنجيء نقول اليوم
قطر عمله نظام الكفاله اللي كان هو بياذي
كل العمال المهاجرين يا اللي اسس هذا
النظام هو بريطاني واسسه بالبحرين سنه 60
هذا النظام قدر كان ومش دفاعا عن قطر كان
هي اول بلد بتشيل نظام الكفاله يعني هو
احنا بنتبع هذا الشيء اللي هو كان موجود
بكل الخليج
همم الشوط الثاني اللي بنحكي فيه همم
بدي اخليك معي اول شيء بس لانه على مساله
نظام الكفاله اتفضل الغاء نظام الكفاله في
عام 2020 يعني بعد 10 سنوات
للعمال والايادي العامله هناك ارقام ايضا
معي همم
العمال الاجانب او مساله الثانيه
المساله الثانيه انه هي مبالغ فيه نوع من
العنصريه تحديدا الميديا الاجنبيه اتجاه
دوله قطر واتجاه العرب لان نفس المشاكل
كانت موجوده بروسيا روسيا ما بتدعم
الحريات دروسها ما بتدعم حوريه الافراد
روسيا مافي عندك اي دعم لا حقوق المثليين
بروسيا كلها الامور ما كانت موجوده امك
حملات المقاطع وكل الحملات اللي كانت ما
كانت موجوده ليه لانه الاوروبيين معودين
انه من اوروبا الشرقيه بس يعني
الموضوع لما كانت لما كانت المانيا
وهنجري يا دولي بالاتحاد
المصريين وانا ضد هذا الموضوع
المثليين رفضوا الهنجري ما قدروا يعاقبهم
وهي دوله الاتحاد الاوروبي ان احنا ما عم
نقدر نغير دوله بالاتحاد الاوروبي بقى
نفرض على قطر هي تغير يعني ازدواج بالنسبه
اليك
لا ليس موافق على ان تحمل شعارات من هذا
النوع في مباريات كره القدم
مع انه عندي بس احنا الدول الاوروبيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي نفرض عليها هذا الموضوع
طيب ازدواجيه في المعايير منير ماذا تقول
تفضل همم
فلسطين اهم من قضيه الممثلين المصريين عشر
سكان العالم 700 مليون شخص
في الدول العربيه
يحاكمون ويسجنون ويعدمون
وليس له لهم ايه حقوق يعني همم
العرب والمسلمون لما يتعلق الامر مش
فلسطين يرفعون وانما يكون في اعلام
المصريه
اسال بشير امين بشير ما رايك بهذا الجدل
يعني اليوم همم للاسف غالبا ما تربت كره
القدم بالتحديد كره القدم لانها من اكثر
شعبيه في العالم تربت بالملفات السياسيه
هل هناك فعلا ازدواجيه في المعايير في
النظر الى الامور لان ربما قطر دوله عربيه
تادينها الاسلام ينظر اليها بطريقه معينه
ام انك تفترض ان المشكل في مكان اخر ربما
رياضيه اجتماعيه فمن طبيعي انه يكون فيها
السياسه بالعكس انا او يشجع ان يكون فيها
السياسه عن طريق كره القدم اليوم القطريون
نفسهم يعترفون والفيفا تعترف بانه عن طريق
كره القدم تغيير الكثير من القوانين في
قطر فبالتالي السياسه كانت ضروريه جدا في
هذا المكان في فرق قطر المشكله على اساس
هوياتي يعني هم اعطوا تنظيم همم كاس
العالم لكوريا واليابان في ال 2002 لانه
هي اول دوله اسيويه تنظم لاحقا جنوب
افريقيا تحت شعار افريقيا فكان الموضوع
انه كل همم لازم تنظم المونديال وهذا يمكن
من الحق لكن هل قطر كانت مستعده قطر لم
تكن مستعده قطر سابقه الزمن استغلت العمال
همم
هناك دوله عربيه مستعده اصلا همم يعني
المغرب حاولت وهي كانت من الدول لراي كان
ممكن تكون مستعد اكثر من قطر وحتى لو ما
كانت مستعدين يمكن كان ممكن يتاجل الموضوع
يعني اذا كان اعطاء همم افضليه الهويه فوق
الافضليه التنظيفيه والبنيه التحتيه لماذا
لذلك انا يعني
اعتقد انه قطر لم تكن مستعده من هذا
الجانب همم
وبالتالي هي يعني ضغطت كل هذه الامور لحتى
همم
كان موجود
فعلا
عندي سؤال لبشير قطر
والمغرب بس ما كانت مستعد بس هي هذه مش
غلطه قطر هي غلطه الفيفا لما تكون الموضوع
لا دوله قطر
ولا فيها صرف صحي ما فيها اي شيء هي قطر
اخلتها قبل انطلاق المونديال في شهر او
شهرين فقدر تخفي الكثير من ال ال المصائب
الي عملت قبل 10 سنين
اول جواب على مساله ملف الحقوق المثليين
وكل الضجه التي اثرت يعني اليوم حول هذه
المساله انه اليوم هناك منع واضح لا نريد
ان نقول كلمه منع ربما هناك تضييق لان بعض
الناس يعني حاولوا ان يعبر عن اختلافه مع
رايهم والاختلاف حق اريد منك تعليق على
مساله حقوق المثليين وتعليق اخر على ما
دار من جد همم
انا رجل اكاديمي اريد ان اقول لك ان
المثليين نوعان نوع همم لديه همم
شيء بيولوجي صفات بيولوجيه يولد
مختلفا يعني احنا عندنا في قطر في هذه
الناحيه يريد ان اؤكد الذين يقولون انه
قطر لتحترم المثليه ولا تدعم المثليين في
بدايه الثمانينات اييه فتاه غير قطريه من
جنسيه اجنبيه
ابوها من احد العمال بالمناسبه يعني في
الدوحه ااه لديها ميول ذكوريه
اجلت لها عمليه اي ترانس جندر اوبريشن
وجميع القطريين تقريبا وجميع الصحف
القطريه ووسائل الاعلام القطريه
الشباب في نادي الاهلي القطري واحدد لك
النادي الاهلي القطري في بدايه الثماني
لتقبل هذا الشخص الجديد الذي عملت عمليه
جراحيه فتحولت الى صبي الى ولد طبعا هو
الولد
يطلق على الجنسين الذكر
الله في اولادكم
طيب وتم استيعاب
اسمحيلي اسمحيلي تم استيعاب هذا
الانسان واصبح ااا صبيا يلعب كره القدم
ودوره قطر حكومه وشعبا ها ومؤسسات دعمت
حقوق هذه هذا الصبي الذي تحول من امراه من
انثى الى ذكر عن طريق عمليه جراحيه على
حساب الدوله ثم ثم
وتغيير الجنس
[موسيقى]
تريدين
ان تقول الكلام الذي انت تحبين ان تقولي
ايضا الذين
في هذا البرنامج فقط ولكن انا اريد ان
اسالك عن ملف حقوق المثليين لا اسال عن
يعني اعطيت مثال
يا سيدتي اين من تحدث عن الهيموفيليا يا
سيدتي منذ سبعينات بدايه السبعينات ونحن
الينا
الاعلام المحليه
والناس الذين يمثلون اليوم الدوله القطريه
والوجوه البارزه تطلق على تويتر وعلى
مواقع التواصل كلمه شواذ عن اعضاء مجتمعين
اجاوب انا احب القطانين واحد العرب واحد
المسلمين وافتخر بذلك انا لا اضع عليهم
نحن كلنا بشر
نحن افراح في كل شيء تقريبا نعم نعم نعم
حقوق المثليين والمثليات منذ السبعينات في
المطاعم وفي الفنادق وسليم هل مسهم ثم ثم
لو ان مشاكل كبيره حصلت للعمال بتتكلم عن
العمال يلعن عمال المونديال لا حدثت ازمات
دبلوماسيه وسياسيه بين الدوله قطر والدول
التي جاء منها هؤلاء العمال بالمناسبه
هؤلاء العمال وجهتهم المفضله الاولى قطر
لماذا هم القطريون القطريون لديهم فهم
يعني قديم يقول نحن لا نريد ان نكون ضد
الاجنبي نحن والزمن معلومات
نعم وجهتهم المفضله قطر ما بين كل دول
الخليج ولا ولكن تسالي طيب اما هذا الذي
حصل اما هذا الذي حصل فهو الدوافع عنصريه
اوروبا اوروبا والعالم الغربي يريد ان
يريد ان يعلمنا الاخلاق نحن نعلمهم
بالاخلاق ماذا فعلت اوروبا وماذا فعلت
شمال امريكا في
سكان الاصليين بالنسبه
ولكن تحدييا ماذا فعل الاوروبيون لو احدد
بلدنا مع بعض الاوروبيون في افريقيا في
فرنسا
همم المستعمرين استغلوا وقتلوا ونكلوا
كثيرا في همم سكان الاصليين في كندا لكن
سكان الاصليين في كندا في 2010 لما كانت
الاولمبياد في بنك كوبر وخرجوا في تظاهرات
لم يجمعهم احد همم عبروا عنهم
هناك هناك فرق بين انه يكون لنا الحق في
الاحتجاج اكيد لا احد همم بريء من هذه
الجرائم همم تاريخيا لكن اليوم نحن نريد
الحق في الاحتجاج اليوم يقمع الناس في
المدرجات في قطر كان في شغله مهمه انه
انتظرنا بدايه المونديال لنرى صحيح على
الاطلاق
قطر لنرى ما هي الذي ستقدمه في هذا
المونديال همم
كل الانتقادات لكن الحقيقه انه بعد بدايه
المونديال قطر همم اظهرت وجها جديدا همم
في منعها لجميع الشعارات على همم في
الاستادات منعت الكحول قبل بدايه
المونديال قطر
انه الفيفا اليوم عم تنجر
مش صحيح
[تصفيق]
اريد ان اسال الان هل يمكن ان لماذا لماذا
اسئل سؤال
التسامح اليوم المشكله اليوم المشكله ان
نحن نعيش في عالم هناك ميثاقيه دوليه تسمى
ميثاقيه حقوق الانسان تعطي مودرن
انا اريد ان اسال اليوم لماذا يقحم الدين
لماذا تضحك ما تسميها وتسميها حضرتك
وتسميها الدوله القطريه تسميها اليوم
القيم الاسلاميه الايمان لماذا لماذا
نتحدث عن هذه يعني لماذا نتحدث عن الدين
بمناسبه رياضيه وتقسم وتقسم العلمانيه في
حياه المسلمين وفي حياه في حياه العرب
لديها وهم فرنسيون
العلمانيه المصريه
يقول ان الثقافه الفرنسيه ثقافه عنصريه هل
قراءه البروفيسور البرنامج وهو فرنسي ومن
هو الفريق الفرنسيه
دوله سرقت افريقيا وسرقت الجزائر
على الموضوع
نعمل البتابا هوتزم انه اذا شو بيعملوا شو
بيعمل الفلسطيني
نحنا في موضوع
يعني اليوم منع الشعارات السياسيه عن
المدرجات مش قطر اللي وراها لان بقلب
الملعب ستورن من سكيورتي ايفاند كل من
الفيفا انا بتذكر وصارت معي معلش شخصيا يا
عم 2018 كنا مدينه فوقها منع كبر يمنعه
علم عليه رقم 74 ده عدت شهداء شهداء
الاهلي لانه اعتبره هذا الشعار لانه هذا
ما بيمسح كره القدم لما بعدين شرح له دخل
حدا انه هذا تابع نادي كره قدم هو النادي
الاهلي المصري رجع اسامه
قطر متحكم بالفيفا هي الفيفا بتمنع هو
الاشياء والموضوع الكحول بالمدرجات يعني
انا
يمكن بشكل يومي الافضل مايكون فيه الكحول
افضل مايكون في كحول بمدرجات اول شيء فيها
اطفال ومدرجات مختلطه لان المشجعين من
الفريقان سوا احنا عملناه المشجعين ممكن
يكونوا معصبين لما يكون فريق عم بنزيد
عليها انتوكسيشن
لانه اريد ان اسمع راي منير ومحمد البشريه
وبريطانيا
في الاماكن العامه وهذا تقريبا
اسلاميه وقيم عربيه ومنعته قبل بدايه
المونديال بيومين لحتى الناس
تشتريات لحتى لو اعلنت هذا الموضوع قبل
شهور كان راح يكون في جدال في الاعلام
فتجنب ذلك واعلامته قبل 48 ساعه فقط من
الولاده طيب
اليس كون قطر والعربيه اليوم يعرضها لنوع
من الجلد المبالغ فيه ربما يعني هل يمكن
ان نقول ان ننكر وجود هذا الامر بالمطلق
انا اريد ان اعود بشكل خاص الى النقطه
التي ذكر همم سيد علي القيم الاسلاميه همم
نبيله التي نحترموها جميعا همم التي اثرت
على طفولتي انا بشكل خاص مثلا همم اريد ان
اقتبس من سيده من النيبال التي تقول الان
كل شيء محطم الحياه نفسها اصبحت مثل مراه
مكسوره فقدت زوجها في في قطر
هذه السيده تعيش مع اطفالها
ب 2000
روبين ما تعادل 16 دولار امريكي في الشهر
ولا تتقاضى اي تعويضات من من الحكومه
القطريه
سيده اخرى
بالم ان تكون وحيدا امرا صعب
اقتباسات من منظمه العفو الدولي
[موسيقى]
طفولته وان نجعل الاطفال يعيشون
حيث العيش فيها صعب طيب
لما مساله القيم الاسلاميه في مكان ما
وتهمل في اماكن اخرى منير لو سمحت علق
لانه سله زمان ما سمعنا رايك تفضل
لحظه دكتور علي لحظه لحظه دكتور
منير قنبله
عن سوريا
ايوه فيما يخص حقوق المثليين في قطر قطر
دوله تحكم بسجن المثليين مده سبع سنوات
ويصير الحكم الى الاعدام في قطر قطر دوله
مجرمه في حق المثليين تقوم بعمليات
التحويل القسري عمليات جراحيه لتحويل
المثليين الى ايلات بقطع اعضائهم
التناسليه وهذا بشهاده طبيب قطري لاجئ في
امريكا
فليس هناك اي احترام في قطر حقوق المثليين
والسيد علي من قطر له خلق بين المثليه
والعمره
قد يسالك اليوم الدول العالم كلها تعرف ان
هذا الامر موجود وفق هذه التقارير في قطر
لماذا تم اختيار قطر هل تتحمل اليوم قطر
مسؤوليه هذا الاختيار يعني اختاروا قطر
ومن ثم نحمل قطر المسؤوليه ونحن نعرف اصلا
ان قطر فيها قوانين هكذا
قلت لك منذ قليل ان مرفقه 24
حوله الشبهات رشاوي رهيبه
وقطر اشترت عمليه تنظيم كاس العالم على ان
تم تشبهها تحوم حولها اعطيني دليل واحده
اعضاء اللجنه التي اختارت ملف قطر
الدكتور علي تفضل
بس بس ااا بشير من ما تحاكم بلاتيني كثير
بموضوع الرشاوي وانا بيه رايي
بلاتر بلاتر رافض قطر تاخذ المونديال قطر
الظريف كاس العالم وهو كان شايف انه هي
اللي كانت كثيره ما بتسمح لتاخذ كاس
العالم بس الفرق انه كان متوقع
شو اسمه مستشاره اللي زعبه بعد بسنه كانوا
موقعين انه قطر ما بتخدها وكان على المسرح
لما قال اسم قطر قال لمستشار اتضحك لانه
في كاميرات بيوجعنا ههه
طيب
ما عم بنصف قطر بانه هي كانت انظف شيء طيب
الدكتور علي تفضل باختصار شديد لو سمحت
لانه نريد ان نخطبه اللجنه قالت ان قطر
كانت انظف شيء وعلى اساسي انها انظف شيء
اختير ملفها لكي تستضيف كاس العالم بعد
اثنتي عشر سنه الكلام هذا كان فعل 2010
والاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم اقوى من الامم
المتحده ولم يثبت اعيدوا اكرر الاسد يبدو
ان الاخ منير لم يسمع الكلام جيدا اعيدوا
اكرر اعيد واكرر ان الرشاوه التي يتحدثون
عنها لم يتم اثباته على الاطلاق كل ما حدث
انه اوروبا اخذتها العزه بالاذن او ربه
تعتقد ان هذه قطر كانت محميتها لحد سنه
تواحد 70 فكيف يمكن لمحميتها ان تستضيف
اكبر مناسبه لكاس العالم اول دوله في
العالم العربي في العالم الاسلامي في
الشرق الاوسط في العالم النامي بين قوسين
يسمون العالم الناميه
بدات تسيس بدات تجنب ما يسمى بمنظمات حقوق
الانسان ونحن نعرف ان هذه المنظمات منظمات
منافقه كالشركات الغربيه التي تعمل في
الخليج العربي
كل هذا الجدل همم ما زلت تشاهد كره القدم
كره القدم نعم
هي هي لعبه الفقراء هي لعبه
هي شغف ننتظره كل اربع سنوات
والمشكله يعني انا ببين المشكله
ننتقد قدر لاقصى حد بنقدر عليه حدث انه
محتاج لكن المظل الاكبر
يا اللي فيها الفساد همم عم ينخرها همم
وبالتالي كان في نفس القضايا بموضوع روسيا
التي كانت تقصف المشافي في سوريا
وفي البرازيل الناس تعيش في العشوائيات
وكان هناك ايضا همم
اللعب اهم
يعني اللعبه هي اصلا وسيلتنا في انه نعبر
عن انفسنا محمد الغربيه كلمه اخيره عن
الفوتبول عن المذيعه القطر لو سمحت يعني
عن سعيد كره القدم لهلا همم جدا ناجح وبس
في شغله
بعد 2018 اللي كان مرشح دروس بري المشرح
بوش قطر هي الولايات المتحده براي العالم
اللي صوتت الاتحاديات اللي صوتت لقطر ولا
روسيا صوت التنكاي حتى ما تشوف وقتها كاس
العالم بريطانيا وامريكا بمباراه تصرفاتهم
بالفيفا طيب
برايك ام منتخب ام انك ترشح منتخبنا
طيب منير لو سمحت اريد منك كلمه ختامين عن
هذه عن هذا العرس العرس الكروي كما يقال
هذا ليس عرس كروي هذا حزن كروي قطر سيست
هذا كاس العالم
واستغلته لنشر ما تدعي انه قيم اس اسلاميه
عن اي اس اي اسلام يرد ان ينشروا في كاس
العالم اسلام بول البعير ومفاقطه الربيع
بدون اهانات اذا بتريد لو سمحت منير يعني
ممكن ان تقول كل ما شئت ولكن بدون اهانه
ولكن اريد دعني اسال دكتور علي هل تسمعني
كلمه اخيره لو سمحت اليوم هل هناك مباراه
من سيفوز بالمباراه النهائيه هل ست- ممكن
اليوم ان تفوز القيم العالميه ستفوز
الثقافه الانسانيه التي توحدت على ارض
الدوحه
500 الف متفرج من جميع زوايا الارض تقريبا
جاءوا الى قطر سهروا في بوتقه واحده
واعجبوا بقطر واعجبوا بالمونديال واعجبوا
بالتنظيم وهذه نسخه قال هاتياني انفانتينو
وينكم لمنير وغير منير ان الجياني انفنتين
واحنا اعطينا فلوس ولا مرجان فيه من احنا
اعطينا فلوس عمره 85 سنه يؤمنوا بالثقافه
الانسانيه وهو ملتي ملياردير انا لا اريد
التحدث ولو اعلق على الهوراء الذي سمعته
في هذا البرنامج
تفضل دكتور محمد استاذ محمد خبرنا رايك
هنادي قتل الاعضاء التناسبيه للمثليين
لتحويلهم الى اياس رغما عنهم طيب لا الى
يعني انتهى الوقت للاسف اريد ان احكي معك
محمد
خلص الوقت او عندي كلمه بعد الاخيره لمحمد
علاء
انا برايي الجميع خاسر في هذا المونديال
واكبر خاسر هو هي الطفوله وهي عوائل هؤلاء
العمال المهاجرين الذين فقدوا حياتهم
الانسانيه التي توحدت على ارض قطر
الذي قال ما تعلمته عن الاخلاق ادين به
للعبه كره القدم